.
Dave!
Dave, was mein...
* Er spricht russisch. *
Brauchen wir so was?
Ja. Hast du das nicht?
Also wir haben zwei Netze.
Echt?- Ja, ja.
Also die Hüte und ein Netz.
Er sagt, das sei das Wichtigste.
- Okay, ja dann ...
Worauf
habe ich mich da nur eingelassen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Wildnis
und jetzt mache ich ausgerechnet
einen Film über Sibirien.
Ich verbinde mit dieser Gegend
eigentlich nur Kälte,
Kargheit und Einsamkeit.
Wie kann man hier leben?
Um das herauszufinden,
reise ich mit Christof Franzen,
Russland-Korrespondent
und Sibirien-Fan.
Der Mann im blauen Jackett
ist unser einheimischer Guide Slava.
* Aufgeregte Rufe, russisch *
(Englisch) Das ist noch gar nichts.
In der Taiga gibt es viele davon.
Die gleichen Insekten.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
(Russisch) Vielleicht schafft man es
bis zur Hälfte der Strecke
und bleibt dann stecken.
Wegen des Hochwassers,
weil es so viel regnet.
Dann muss man warten,
bis das Wasser wieder sinkt.
Das sind alles
Bergbäche oder -flüsse,
die dann immer höher werden.
Und da müssen wir überall durch?
Und auf einmal kommst du nicht mehr
vorwärts, nicht mehr rückwärts.
Okay.
Da kannst du,
wenn es gut geht, zwei Tage,
wenn es schlecht geht,
bis zu zehn Tage warten.
Okay.
Ja.
Die Wolken über dem Hotel verheissen
nichts Gutes für unser Abenteuer.
Morgen werden wir die Stadt verlassen
und in die absolute Wildnis reisen.
Zu Rentiernomaden
am äussersten Rand Sibiriens.
Wir befinden uns 5'000 km östlich
von Moskau in der Stadt Jakutsk.
Von hier fahren wir 1'200 km
auf einer
der gefährlichsten Strassen der Welt
in die Goldgräberstadt Ust-Nera.
Von unserem Zielort Sasyr
soll ein Lastwagen kommen,
der uns dort abholt.
Dann geht es 200 km durch ein Gebiet
ohne jegliche Strassen,
zu den Rentiernomaden.
Mein Begleiter Christof
war schon mal in Sasyr,
einem der abgelegensten Orte
Sibiriens.
Für ihn war es
eine der schönsten Drehreisen
seiner gesamten Korrespondentenzeit.
Er porträtierte
den Nomadenjungen Christofor.
Dabei erlebte er Momente,
die ihn bis heute beeindrucken.
Z.B. Christofors Versuch,
ein junges Rentier zu retten.
Die Mutter wollte es nicht säugen.
Gib ihm den Finger.
Hauptsache ist, dass das Kleine
endlich zu saugen anfängt.
Ja, es saugt, es saugt.
Ein kleines bisschen.
Alles Menschenmögliche wurde getan.
Jetzt sollte die Natur entscheiden,
ob das kleine Rentier überlebt.
Eine Kindheit
mit grosser Verantwortung,
aber auch grosser Freiheit.
Das hat Christof beeindruckt.
Er sagte mir, wenn ich mich
für Sibirien interessiere,
dann solle ich ihn begleiten,
zurück an diesen abgelegenen Ort.
Er wolle sowieso wissen,
wie es Christofor heute geht
und ob das Leben dort
immer noch so ursprünglich ist
wie in seiner Erinnerung.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Schon kurz nach der Stadt Jakutsk
ist die Strasse
nur noch eine Schotterpiste.
Russland ist so riesig,
dass man sogar bei einem Inlandflug
einen Jetlag bekommt.
Elf Zeitzonen gibt es hier.
Vor sieben Jahren reiste Christof
bequem per Helikopter.
Wir machen es wie die Einheimischen
und fahren über Land, Sibirien total.
* Freizeichen *
Wie ist die Situation bei euch?
Das Wasser kommt.
Der Truck
ist noch nicht losgefahren, oder?
Nein, noch nicht.
Unser Fahrer Sergej soll uns
die 1'200 km bis Ust-Nera bringen.
Doch es ist nicht klar, ob wir
von dort überhaupt weiterkommen.
Seit zehn Tagen
gibt es in der ganzen Region
immer wieder starke Regenfälle.
Wir sind unterwegs
auf der Kolyma-Road,
der einzigen Strasse,
die die Städte Magadan, Jakutsk
und Ust-Nera verbindet.
Die Strasse wird auch
Strasse der Knochen
oder Strasse des Todes genannt,
weil sie von Gulag-Häftlingen
erbaut wurde.
In den 30er-Jahren
fanden sie hier Gold.
Sobald sie davon wussten,
brauchten sie Strassen.
Da brauchten sie
billige Arbeitskräfte.
Gulag, so wurden Straflager
zur Stalin-Zeit genannt.
Darin kamen Millionen Menschen
ums Leben.
Allein für diese 2'000 km lange
Strasse starben Zehntausende.
Jakutien
ist die grösste Region Sibiriens
und die kälteste bewohnte Region
der Erde.
Im Winter wird es kälter als -60 °C.
Im Winter ist es schwer,
einen Toten zu begraben.
Dafür muss man die Erde auftauen.
Als die Strasse gebaut wurde,
warf man die Leichen
einfach in den entstandenen Graben.
Die Überreste liegen eigentlich
noch unter der Strasse.
Eine geschichtliche Aufarbeitung
des Gulag-Systems
hat in Russland
nie wirklich stattgefunden.
Gerade unter Putin werden starke
Führer wieder vermehrt propagiert.
Eine aktuelle Umfrage in Russland
zur bedeutendsten Person der
Weltgeschichte ergab: Josef Stalin.
Auf den gesamten 1'200 km
entdecken wir ganze zwei Mahnmale.
Gestiftet nicht vom Staat,
sondern von Privatpersonen.
* Majestätische Gitarrenmusik *
Dann erreichen wir
das Ostsibirische Bergland.
Zum ersten Mal sehe ich,
wie schön Sibirien sein kann.
Wunderschön, aber gefährlich.
* Christof Franzen
spricht russisch. *
* Er spricht russisch. *
Eingeschlafen ist er.
Hilft der Rettungsdienst nicht?
Woher soll hier
ein Rettungsdienst kommen?
Braucht er irgendetwas zu essen
oder zu trinken?
Zu essen habe ich.
Er hat mir einen Zettel
mit Handynummern gegeben,
die ich anrufen soll.
Wir haben ein Satellitentelefon,
ruf doch gleich jetzt an.
Ich habe ihm doch
einen Zettel gegeben.
Ruf doch selbst an.
Erst als er merkt, dass wir kein Geld
wollen, nimmt er unser Angebot an.
Hallo, privet.
Ich bin in den Graben gefahren,
eingeschlafen.
Ja, ich scheine ganz zu sein.
Weisst du, wie viele in Russland
pro Jahr auf der Strasse
ums Leben kommen?
- Nein.
Schätz mal.
2'000.
- 27'000.
27'000?
- Mhm.
Seine Retter sind 1'000 km entfernt.
Das bedeutet auf dieser Strasse
mindestens zwei Tage.
Es gäbe eigentlich einen Dienst.
V.a. für den Winter,
wenn's lebensgefährlich ist
oder für ganz grosse Unfälle.
Aber für solche "Kleinigkeiten" ...
Hilf dir selbst,
sonst hilft dir keiner.
Die Kolyma-Strasse
befindet sich bis heute im Bau.
An einigen Stellen
muss man immer noch die Fähre nehmen.
Wie ist das Leben hier?
Normal? Stabil?
Nestabilny.
- Nestabilny?
Wir haben keine Arbeit.
Jakutien ist die reichste Gegend.
Es soll hier
Gold und Edelsteine geben,
im Fernsehen
sagen das zumindest alle.
Ich bin trotzdem kein Millionär.
Aber irgendwelche Kerle kommen
hier an und werden Milliardär.
Gibt es Konflikte untereinander?
Konflikte gibt es sogar
zwischen Mann und Frau.
Zuerst sagt man "Ich liebe dich"
und dann will man sich umbringen.
Russen machen das so:
"Ich küsse dich, ich küsse dich,
ich bringe dich um."
"Als Gott die Erde erschuf,
schickte er einen Engel
mit einem Sack voller Reichtümer
über Sibirien."
"Als dieser Jakutien überflog,
wurden ihm vor Kälte die Finger steif
und er liess alles fallen."
"Aus Zorn über seinen Verlust
strafte er diese Region jedoch
mit ewigem Winter."
Heute gehört Jakutien zu Russland.
Sechsmal so gross wie Deutschland,
hat es nur 1 Mio. Einwohner.
Die Menschen, die wir hier treffen,
sind überwiegend Jakuten.
Russen kamen erst in der Sowjetzeit.
* Geheimnisvolle, trommelndey Musik *
Ist das ein Dorf?
Ja, das ist ein Dorf.
Da hast du es.
Früher war in dem Haus
unten eine Gaststätte.
Das war vor 20 Jahren.
Jetzt ist dort niemand mehr?
Und warum?
Die landwirtschaftlichen Betriebe
sind auseinandergefallen.
Die Strasse
wurde nicht mehr instand gehalten.
Es gibt kein fliessendes Wasser,
keine Heizung.
Im Winter ist es unmöglich,
hier zu leben.
* Grillen *
* Monotone,
melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Christof erzählt mir etwas,
das für diese Region
bezeichnend zu sein scheint:
Seit Februar 2017 kann hier
jeder Russe 1 ha Land bekommen.
Gratis.
Wenn er sich dazu verpflichtet,
diesen zu bewirtschaften.
Dieses Regierungsprogramm
stösst bisher aber
nur auf geringes Interesse.
Ich interessiere mich
für das Leben in ganz Sibirien.
Bei der Vorbereitung auf diesen Film
bin ich auf eine Geschichte
von zwei Menschen gestossen,
die freiwillig unter
besonders harten Umständen leben.
Schon vor zwei Monaten reiste ich
deshalb das erste Mal überhaupt
nach Russland,
in die Region Krasnojarsk.
Knapp 3'000 km von hier entfernt,
und doch auch Sibirien.
* Perlende Klavier-
und Klarinettenmusik *
Tief im unendlich scheinenden Wald
filmte ich
eine kleine dramatische Geschichte.
Nur wenig erinnert daran,
dass hier noch vor 20 Jahren
das Dorf Lokatuy stand,
mit über 500 Einwohnern,
Krankenhaus und Geschäften.
Jeder, der hier gelebt hat,
erinnert sich an alles und jeden.
Und daran,
wie hier gearbeitet wurde.
Natürlich ist es manchmal traurig.
Ich habe meine ganze Jugend
hier verbracht.
Das Haus von Anatoliy Luzan
und seiner Frau Ludmilla
ist das einzige, das noch steht.
Sie sind die letzten Einwohner
von Lokatuy.
Bei meinem Besuch
waren die beiden ziemlich aufgeregt.
Enkelsohn Igor
wollte zu Besuch kommen
und er hätte eigentlich
schon längst da sein sollen.
Aber es klingelt doch.
Ja, schon das fünfte Mal.
Wahrscheinlich liegt das Handy
irgendwo draussen.
Sie kommen nicht so häufig.
Die Strassen sind zwar gut,
aber es ist eine weite Strecke.
Pack alles ein,
was deine Mama dir sagt.
(Kind)
Ich bringe euch ein Geschenk mit.
Nein, das musst du nicht,
du bist unser Geschenk.
Igor wohnt im 1 1/2 Std. entfernten
Städtchen Nischni Ingasch.
Sein Onkel soll ihn eigentlich
bringen, doch der ist unauffindbar.
Genug Zeit also,
um den Haushalt zu erledigen.
Wie oft kocht ihr auf diese Art?
Immer wenn der Strom ausfällt.
Wie oft ist das?
Oft. Manchmal eine Woche lang.
Für die Hunde
kochen wir immer hier draussen.
Zumindest fürs Trinkwasser
gibt es eine verlässliche Quelle.
Allerdings 500 m vom Haus entfernt.
Ist es schwer?
Ich bin es gewohnt.
Für einen Mann, der
sein ganzes Leben gearbeitet hat,
ist es schwieriger, faul zu sein.
Anatoliy ist 65 Jahre alt
und war Techniker.
Seine Frau Ludmilla
war Gefängnisaufseherin
und hat auch schon das Rentenalter
von 58 erreicht.
Ihre Rente von 250 Euro können sie
oftmals gar nicht ausgeben,
denn das nächste Dorf
ist 11 km entfernt
und sie besitzen kein Auto.
Das meiste finden sie
im Wald und Garten.
Tiere halten sie nicht,
das würde Bären anlocken.
Ab und zu fahren Angler vorbei
oder Lkw auf dem Weg
zu einer nahegelegenen Kiesgrube,
dem letzten Betrieb in der Gegend.
An den gerodeten Flächen
kann man erkennen,
dass Lokatuy noch zu Sowjetzeiten
ein Zentrum für Holzwirtschaft war.
Es gab auch mehrere
landwirtschaftliche Kolchosen.
Nach dem Ende der Sowjetunion
wurden die Betriebe geschlossen.
Nach und nach
verschwand die Infrastruktur
und mit ihr die Menschen.
Immer noch Warten auf Igor.
* Hinweiston Verbindungsprobleme *
Niemand erreichbar.
Igor sagt immer:
"Mach Pfannkuchen, die mag ich".
Fühlen Sie sich einsam,
wenn das Haus leer ist?
Ja,
dann ist es einsam und langweilig.
* Grillenzirpen, einzelne Fliegen *
Vielleicht kommt heute
gar niemand mehr.
Um Sie herum lebt niemand.
Warum ziehen Sie nicht weg?
Ich liebe die Natur.
Wenn ich in der Taiga herumlaufe,
habe ich vor niemandem Angst.
In der Stadt Krasnojarsk hat mir mal
jemand meine Mütze geklaut
und mir auf den Kopf geschlagen.
Wer soll mir hier in der Taiga
etwas tun?
* Ruhige,
Western-artige Gitarrenmusik *
* Seufzen *
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Hast du uns vermisst?
Ja, und wie. Dich und Oma.
Wie gefällt es dir hier?
- Sehr.
Und was gefällt dir besonders?
Der Wald.
Der Wald? Und was noch?
Alles.
Das war mein erster
überraschender Eindruck von Sibirien.
Sommerlich warm ...
... eine fast märchenhafte Idylle
und Menschen,
die ihr herausforderndes Leben
ganz bewusst so gewählt haben.
Wird das gehen?
Die Reifen
müssen ja gewaschen werden.
* Treibende Gitarrenmusik *
Die Kolyma-Strasse
taucht in vielen Top-10-Listen
als eine der gefährlichsten Strassen
der Welt auf.
Sogar Reifentests
werden hier durchgeführt.
Da kann etwas schamanischer Beistand
nicht schaden.
Wie viel hast du gegeben?
- 2 Rubel.
Ah, siehst du.
So viel ist dir das Glück wert.
10 Cent.
Wäre ich mal nicht so geizig gewesen.
Die erste Raststätte seit Stunden
und die vielen Fahrzeuge
sind kein gutes Zeichen.
Und tatsächlich erfahren wir,
dass 25 km weiter
die ganze Strasse
weggeschwemmt worden sein soll.
Sobald wir die Ferienwohnung
erreichen, melden wir uns nochmals.
Heute Nacht
schaffen wir es nicht mehr.
* Dröhnendes Pumpen *
Sergej montiert
unseren letzten Ersatzreifen,
dann fahren wir ins Ungewisse.
* Aus dem Autoradio:
"Stayin' Alive" von den Bee Gees *
# Feel the city breakin'
and everybody shakin'
# and we're stayin' alive,
stayin' alive.
# Ah, ha, ha, ha, stayin' alive,
# Ah, ha, ha, ha, stayin' alive.
* Die Musik geht
in sanfte Gitarrenklänge über. *
Die Leute haben gesagt, nach 25 km
komme die weggespülte Stelle.
Aber wir sind schon 30 km gefahren.
Entweder haben sie sich
in der Angabe geirrt
oder wir sind schon vorbei.
Die Bagger haben es wohl schon
zugeschüttet.- Okay, na dann.
So wie es aussieht,
ist das nichts mit Schlafen.
Im Auto übernachten.
Das ist meine Meinung.
- Wäre auch okay.
Er hat sich schon gefreut, dass er
jetzt etwas Wodka trinken kann.
Jetzt muss er halt
noch 3-4 Std. fahren.
Sie haben gesagt 20,
wir sind fast 40 gefahren.
Sie haben sich verschätzt.
- Ah, Mist.
Hello!
Wie geht's da drüben?
Auf dem Weg nach Sasyr
kann es theoretisch bei jedem Fluss
das Gleiche sein.
* Poppige Discomusik *
Modern Talking.
* Lachen *
* "You Can Win If You Want"
von Modern Talking *
# You packed your things
in a carpetbag,
# left and never looking back.
# Rings on your fingers,
paint on your toes,
# music where ever you go.
Die Rohre unter der Strasse konnten
der Strömung nicht standhalten.
Es hat sie weggeschwemmt.
Jetzt versuchen wir
eine Durchfahrt zu machen.
Wie lange dauert das?
Das hängt alles davon ab,
wie schnell das Wasser sinkt.
Je schneller,
desto besser kommen wir voran.
Jeder Fluss ist einmalig.
Haben Sie gesehen, wie tief der ist?
Wir schütten es rein,
es wird wieder weggeschwemmt,
dann bleibt die Tiefe genau gleich.
Gibt es eine Alternative,
das zu umfahren?
Nein,
dort sieht es noch schlimmer aus.
Das passiert jedes Jahr.
Einige Orte sind schwach,
man müsste sie verstärken.
Dafür bräuchte man Geld.
Jetzt baut man die Brücke
auf der Krim.
Ja, dort wird die Brücke gebaut.
Hier haben wir einen Dreck,
solche Brücken.
* Fernöstlich anmutende Saitenmusik *
Im besten Fall also
nur den ganzen Tag warten.
Zumindest hat das Wasser
den Höchststand wohl hinter sich.
Für unsere Mitwartenden
scheint die Situation
nicht so aussergewöhnlich zu sein.
Christof sagt mir, er habe schon
bei seinem letzten Besuch gemerkt,
dass die Zeit in Jakutien
mit anderen Massstäben gemessen wird.
(Originalkommentar)
Sasyr ist ein 700-Einwohner-Dorf,
im Umkreis von 200 km
nichts als Taiga, Berge und Flüsse.
Hier gehen die Kinder
der Rentiernomaden zur Schule
und verbringen
geschlagene neun Monate im Jahr
getrennt von ihren Familien
und ihren Rentierherden.
Christofor lebt während der
Schulzeit im Haus seiner Cousine.
Hier im Dorf ist er schweigsam
und redet kaum ein Wort mit mir.
Heute steht
eine Prüfung in Geschichte an,
und er
ist kein besonders guter Schüler.
Welches Land
gilt als Wiege der Demokratie?
A: das Römische Reich,
B: Griechenland,
C: Ägypten
oder D: Indien?
Die Geschichtslehrerin
stellt sechs solche Fragen.
Ob die Nachbarin wohl mehr weiss?
Christofor, wie viele richtige?
- Eine.
Christofor nimmt es gelassen.
Erst beim Bilden von Sätzen wird mir
klar, wo er mit seinen Gedanken ist.
Sobald die Schule zu Ende ist, reise
ich sofort zu meinen Rentieren.
Nach zwölf langen Stunden geht es
endlich weiter Richtung Ust-Nera.
Spasibo. Do svidaniya.
* Nachdrückliche, unruhige Klänge *
Etwas zu überschwänglich.
Der Taxifahrer ist ein guter Typ,
dass er uns hilft.
Das ist selbstverständlich.
- Ist das nordische Solidarität?
Nein, wir nehmen natürlich
600 Euro von euch.
Vielleicht ist es bei euch
hinter der Grenze anders,
aber bei uns hilft man einander.
Ich beginne zu verstehen,
warum Christof mir so
von der nordischen Solidarität
vorgeschwärmt hat.
Unser Fahrer Sergej sagt mir,
ohne sich gegenseitig zu helfen,
hätte man hier draussen keine Chance.
Ich habe den Kontakt
von einem Fahrer,
der uns von Ust-Nera
nach Sasyr mitnimmt.
Wenn wir dort ankommen,
machen wir alles ab:
Was es kostet,
wann wir fahren und alles.
* Mystische Musik *
Leninstrasse 29.
Hier liegt unsere Ferienwohnung.
Wir sind
in der Goldgräberstadt Ust-Nera.
Mündung der Nera
bedeutet dieser Name,
und die Flüsse führen Hochwasser.
Angeblich sieht es bei uns
deshalb so aus.
Wir wissen nicht, ob es Sinn macht,
Richtung Sasyr aufzubrechen.
Ein längerer Aufenthalt hier ist aber
auch keine verlockende Alternative.
Unsere einzige Hoffnung ist Vasily,
ein Fahrer aus Sasyr,
der hier
zusammen mit seinen Passagieren
wohl schon seit zwei Wochen
festsitzt.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Wir waren schon mal in Sasyr
zum Filmen, vor sieben Jahren.
In der Schule und so.
Jetzt wollen wir wieder dorthin,
mit Ihnen.
Unser Auto, damit fahren wir.
Sicher?
- Ja, morgen wahrscheinlich.
Oh!
Hat's Platz?
(Lachend) Wo wir noch Pla...
Eine Fischerrute hat's.
Eine Angelrute, wie ihr sagt.
- Und ein Boot?
Ja, ja, aber dafür
hat's noch ein paar Fässer, Räder.
Ja, hat's noch Platz für uns?
- Nein, keine Ahnung wie die da ...
Also wenn der sagt,
es kommen noch zwölf andere mit ...
Wie lange brauchen wir?
Zwei Tage oder einen Monat,
alles ist möglich.
Wann fahren wir morgen?
Erst mal
versuchen wir herauszufinden,
ob man durchfahren kann.
Dort hinten gibt es Goldgräber,
die wissen es sicher.
In den Bergen um Ust-Nera
gibt es riesige Goldvorkommen.
Angeblich noch über 100 t.
Aktuell 7'000 Seelen
hat das Gold hierhergelockt.
In eine eigentlich superreiche Stadt.
* Tragende,
melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Sind Sie schon
Ihr ganzes Leben hier?
Seit 1979.
Woher sind Sie gekommen?
Ukraine.
Ukraine. Wieso von so weit weg?
Wegen der Liebe?
(Lachend) Nein, wegen des Geldes.
Lohnt es sich?
Für die Regierung oder für uns?
Für Sie.
Ich habe beinahe mein ganzes Leben
hier verbracht
und es war
nicht wirklich profitabel.
Die Rente ist etwas höher
als in meiner Heimat,
und dort ist es dann mehr wert.
Man gewöhnt sich daran.
Man kommt nicht mehr weg von hier.
Natürlich ist es kalt,
und vom Frost wird man müde.
Ständig nur Frost.
Wir besuchen den Mann,
der das Gold abbaut.
Man sagte uns, der lokale Oligarch
sei Journalisten gegenüber sehr offen
und zeigefreudig.
Tatsächlich
wird uns eine Audienz gewährt.
Gehen wir?
Der Oligarch heisst Alexander Karas.
Viele Internetseiten warnen davor,
bei ihm zu arbeiten.
Löhne würden nicht ausbezahlt.
Und er sei schon mal
im Gefängnis gewesen,
weil er als Angestellter
einst Gold gestohlen habe.
Piotr, gibt es einen Weg nach Sasyr?
Erkundige dich bitte mal.
* Verzerrte Stimme *
Ja, ich warte, Piotr.
Bevor wir etwas erfahren,
lässt der Chef bitten.
Kommt jetzt mit.
Wir wissen eigentlich gar nicht
genau, was wir hier wollen,
aber wann trifft man schon mal
einen waschechten Oligarchen?
Zdravstvuyte!
Zdravstvuyte. Christof Franzen,
televideniye shveytsarskoye.
Zdravstvuyte!
Das ist unser Regisseur Dave.
Spasibo.
Ich rede nur zum Nutzen Russlands.
Was heisst das, "zum Nutzen"?
Alles, was im Rahmen
unseres Interesses ist,
dem des Volkes und des Präsidenten.
Der Präsident gibt uns
die Möglichkeit, hier zu arbeiten.
Wenn wir mit den Leuten hier reden,
sagen die,
dass es hier zwar viel Geld gibt,
sie aber zu wenig davon bekommen,
weil das meiste nach Moskau gehe.
Ich weiss nicht, wer so was sagt.
Die müssen unnormal sein.
Wir arbeiten einfach.
Und Moskau muss auch Moskau sein,
es ist die Hauptstadt.
Wir helfen auch Studenten,
Rentnern, Veteranen und Invaliden.
Nicht nur in Moskau,
es geht in alle Regionen.
So viele Kinder im Waisenhaus -
wer würde sonst für sie aufkommen?
Haben Sie gar nichts zu klagen?
Wie kann man sich
gegenüber der Heimat beklagen?
Ich bin ein Patriot.
Ihr seid zu viert, oder?
Wir schauen mal, ob wir euch mit
dem Hubschrauber dorthin bringen.
Wir wollen den Weg dorthin filmen.
Unser Regisseur will es so.
Woher kommt er?
Er ist Deutscher.
Es ist nicht die Nation,
die schlecht ist,
es sind immer die Menschen.
Bevor wir gehen,
liest er uns noch ein Zitat
von Joseph Goebbels
auf seinem Handy vor und sagt uns,
wir müssten unbedingt
noch seinen Park besichtigen.
* Glockige Musik *
Die neueste Attraktion
ist ein Denkmal
für die kleinen grünen Männchen.
Christof sagt mir,
dass so die Soldaten genannt werden,
welche die Krim eroberten.
Gleich hinter dem Park: die hohe Nera
und endlich
die gewünschten Informationen.
Was sagt der Polizeichef?
Es gibt keine Strasse nach Sasyr.
Inwiefern? Dort gibt es ja
allgemein keine Strassen.
Es gibt keine Durchfahrt,
der Wasserpegel ist zu hoch.
Wenn er hier so hoch ist,
dann dort auch.
Nein,
ihr werdet nie bis dorthin kommen.
Der Tag endet stilecht:
Stromausfall in der ganzen Stadt.
Kennst du den Wetterbericht, Vasily?
Es soll wieder regnen,
und es hat jetzt schon Hochwasser.
Ja?
Der Verkehrspolizist sagte,
man komme nicht bis Sasyr.
Ich glaube, vom Wetter her geht es.
Wir fahren los.
Was machen wir, wenn wir mittendrin
sind und das Wasser wieder steigt?
Dann machen wir es einfach
wie der Kuckuck und warten.
Bis das Abenteuer beginnt, müssen wir
noch Zeit totschlagen in Ust-Nera.
Zumindest gibt es ein Museum,
finanziell unterstützt
vom Oligarchen.
In diesem Raum
geht es um die Kolyma-Strasse.
Eine traurige Geschichte.
Mein Büro ist genau gegenüber.
Ich weiss nicht,
vielleicht bin ich zu emotional.
Ich glaube,
ich höre Stöhnen und Geräusche.
Auch wenn man mich
dafür erschiessen würde -
nie würde ich nachts
ins Museum gehen.
Nicht mal mein Hund
traut sich nachts her.
So eine Anhäufung von Not,
so viel Schmerz,
und all das in einem Raum.
Irgendeine Energie
ist hiergeblieben.
* Glockige Musik,
dunkle Streicherklänge *
Bilder von Häftlingen gibt es keine.
Es war wohl strikt verboten,
sie zu fotografieren.
Trotzdem ist hier der erste
richtige Gedenkort für die Opfer,
den wir sehen.
Wie das alles gemeint ist,
ist jedoch unklar.
Prangt doch der grosse Stalin
prominent über dem Geschehen.
Ist daran Stalin schuld, oder was?
Das kann man nicht
auf einen Menschen schieben.
Stalin ist Geschichte.
Es war eine Epoche.
War der Preis nicht zu hoch?
Ich habe kein Recht,
das zu beurteilen.
Vielleicht war der Preis hoch.
Aber das Resultat zählt.
Sagen wir es mal so.
Hier, für euch.
Die habe ich
aus einem verlassenen Haus geholt,
damit ihr es bequemer habt.
Vasily, ist das zum Schutz?
Nein, das ist für die Jagd.
Setz dich.
* Treibende Rockmusik *
Ho-hoppla!
Wir sind Touristen.
Unser Russland.
Was, Dave?
Nicht Filmen.
Christof,
wie lange sind wir unterwegs?
Die werden auch wieder mal nüchtern.
Das Wichtigste ist einfach:
unseren Wodka verstecken.
Ich weiss: Solch eine Reise
ist eine einmalige Gelegenheit.
Und doch wäre ich jetzt gerne
da oben im Flugzeug.
Hitler kaputt.
* Ruhige Gitarrenmusik *
Ich will schöne Natur sehen.
Deshalb mache ich diese Reise mit.
Es ist ein langer und schwieriger
Weg, aber exzellente Natur.
Zumindest das.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
* Tragende Musik *
Heute geht es nicht, oder?
Wir warten bis morgen um 6 Uhr
oder bis um 10 Uhr.
Unsere Reisegefährten sind Ewenen.
Eine kleine Volksgruppe
von weniger als 20'000 Menschen
mit eigener Sprache.
Jeder von ihnen scheint
genau zu wissen, wo er anpacken muss.
* Leise Gespräche auf russisch. *
Spasibo.
Kommt, es gibt Tee.
- Spasibo.
Nachts hat es hier selbst im Sommer
kalte 0 °C.
Wir sind so weit im Norden,
dass es nur noch knapp 2 Std.
richtig dunkel wird.
Im Morgengrauen wird schmerzhaft
deutlich, was noch vor uns liegt.
Aha, aha!
Der müde Regisseur.
Film den auch!
- Der schnarchende Superstar.
Er hat mich auch gefilmt,
als ich müde war.
Auch nach der kurzen Nacht
keine wesentliche Veränderung:
Weiterfahrt immer noch unmöglich.
* Langgezogene Gitarrenakkorde *
Von atemberaubender Natur
sind wir noch weit entfernt.
Hier haben wohl unsere Bekannten,
die Goldgräber, gewütet.
Siehst du das Fahrerhäuschen
da hinten?
Da ist ein Lastwagen umgekippt.
Oh, den hat's ja ganz umgedreht.
Ein Ural wie unserer?
Ja.
Und die Leute?
Haben sie es geschafft?
Ja,
sie konnten rechtzeitig springen.
Also, sei vorsichtig.
Es ist sehr gefährlich.
Keine leichte Entscheidung, oder?
Wir müssen gut nachdenken.
So viele Leute.
Kinder, Ausländer.
Das wäre ein Skandal.
Ja, ein internationaler.
Da ist ein Fahrzeug,
der hat es rübergeschafft.
* Der Motor startet zaghaft. *
* Rockige Musik *
Er sagt, wenn dieser hier vorbei
ist, sei das Schlimmste durch.
Meint er.
Wieso meint er das?
Hier müsste eigentlich theoretisch
am meisten Wasser sein,
weil das der unterste Flussteil ist.
Aha.
Wenn wir kippen, sollen wir springen.
Aber in welche Richtung?
* Rattern *
Ich muss etwas Gegengewicht geben.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Hei, ei, ei, ei, ei.
Ich weiss nicht, wie viel Schräglage
er noch ausgehalten hätte.
Vielleicht haben mich
meine 100 kg hier gerettet.
Ja,
vier Reifen sind deshalb geplatzt,
aber hier haben sie uns gerettet.
* Entspannte Mundharmonikamusik *
Leider war die Prognose, was die
abnehmende Tiefe der Flüsse angeht,
total daneben.
1 Std. Gratisflug hätten wir gehabt.
Ja.
Gratisflug ist nur für Oligarchen.
So geht's dahin, Stunde um Stunde,
Fluss um Fluss.
Unsere Arche
riecht nach Abgasen und Menschlichem.
Es ist laut
und immer wenn man kurz einnickt,
kommt ein besonders grosser Stein.
Unsere Mitreisenden
nehmen es mit stoischer Gelassenheit.
Selbst die Kinder beklagen sich nie.
Wie heissen Sie?
- Oigulana.
Wie?
Oigulana.
Wie lange dauert die Fahrt?
Manchmal drei Tage, manchmal zehn.
Zehn Tage?
- Ja.
Einmal sind wir im Winter
bei -50 °C gefahren.
Dann ist uns
das Lenkrad eingefroren.
Wir mussten es
mit dem Gasbrenner wieder auftauen.
Hatten Sie Angst?
- Nein, wir sind daran gewöhnt.
Oigulana ist Biologiestudentin
in Jakutsk
und fährt zweimal im Jahr
heim nach Sasyr.
Sie sagt, im Winter,
wenn alle Flüsse vereist sind,
könne man auf ihnen fahren und so die
gesamte Strecke in 10 Std. schaffen.
Bei meinen Recherchen zu diesem Film
bin ich auch
auf diese Eisstrassen gestossen.
Und auf etwas,
das noch spektakulärer schien:
ein Pferderennen
auf dem gefrorenen Jenissei,
dem längsten Fluss Sibiriens.
Vor fünf Monaten
reiste Christof deshalb für mich
mit der Kamera
in die Region Krasnojarsk.
Er tauchte ein in eine Welt so rau,
wie ich mir Sibirien
immer ausgemalt hatte.
* Wabernde, lauernde Musik *
Abschlusstraining bei -20 °C.
Ich weiss nicht, was er hat.
Er versteht wohl,
dass er morgen einen Auftritt hat.
Er ist ein wenig aufgeregt.
Julia Naoumova lebt in Chernasiorsk.
Ein aussterbendes Dorf,
wie viele in Sibirien.
Vor drei Jahren zog die 26-Jährige
aus der Stadt hierher,
wegen ihrem Freund Albert
und der Pferdefarm seiner Familie.
Das sibirische Leben
ist ziemlich streng, oder?
Na ja, wissen Sie,
man kann sich an alles gewöhnen,
auch an ein strenges Leben.
Ich weiss nicht,
offenbar ist es wegen der Tiere.
Schön. Das ist wahre Liebe.
Ja, das ist wahre Liebe,
nicht nur Arbeit.
Man muss sie lieben.
Wenn ein Mensch sie nicht liebt,
gibt es keine guten Resultate.
Morgen müssen die Wettbewerbspferde
zum Rennen transportiert werden.
Doch Julias Freund Albert
hat Sibirien-typische Probleme.
* Hohes, langgezogenes Pfeifen *
Die Transporter sind tiefgefroren.
* Ratterndes Starten des Motors,
Pfeifen *
Morgen erwarte ich den Sieg.
Nur darauf bin ich eingestellt.
Man darf seine Ziele
nicht zu tief stecken.
Jedes Jahr erarbeiten wir uns
immer die ersten Plätze.
Seit fünf Jahren
konnte uns niemand schlagen.
* Schnauben *
Für das Rennen auf dem Eis
brauchen die Pferde
spezielle Hufeisen mit Spikes.
Pferderennen
sind ein teures Familienhobby.
Die Farm von Alberts Vater
finanziert sich hauptsächlich
durch Rinderzucht.
Ist die Ehre das Wichtigste
oder das Geld?
Nein, ich denke, es ist die Ehre
und die Möglichkeit,
seine Pferde zu zeigen.
Wir streben danach,
noch weiter zu kommen,
nicht nur in Sibirien zu bleiben,
Russland zu bereisen
oder sogar das Ausland.
Waren Sie schon mal im Ausland?
War ich nicht.
Nur in meinen Träumen.
Der grosse Tag bricht an.
Doch Julia bleibt im Haus.
Das Verladen der Pferde
will sie nicht mit ansehen.
* Knurren *
* Rufe *
* Wiehern *
120 km sibirischer Strasse
trennen die Farm von Novoselova,
wo das Ice-Derby stattfindet.
* Russischer Popgesang *
Im Sommer
sieht der riesige Fluss so aus.
Im März jeden Jahres
findet das Rennen statt.
Es reiten Profis und Amateure,
in unterschiedlichsten Kategorien.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Gerade noch rechtzeitig
zur wichtigsten Kategorie.
Beim Rennen im Mehrspänner
lenkt Julias Schwiegervater
höchstpersönlich.
* Lautsprecherdurchsage *
* Pfiffe, Applaus *
Doch dieses Jahr
reicht es nur zum zweiten Platz.
Was war?
- Wir haben verloren.
* Rufe *
Der kleine Disput wird ohne grössere
Handgreiflichkeiten beigelegt.
Für die Familienehre ist es zu spät.
Jetzt geht es um 100 Euro Preisgeld
und v.a. darum,
sich für höhere Ziele
zu präsentieren.
* Wabernde, lauernde Musik *
* Lautsprecherdurchsage *
Vielleicht ist Julia ihrem nächsten
Ziel ein Stückchen nähergekommen.
Sie möchte einmal
bei Putins Präsidenten-Cup in Moskau
teilnehmen.
Ja, wenn wir dieses Ziel erreichen,
steht uns nichts mehr im Weg.
Liegt das im Bereich des Möglichen?
Es gibt nichts Unmögliches,
alles ist möglich.
Wo geht's nach Sasyr?
Gibt es einen Weg?
Nein,
der Regen hat alles weggespült.
Jetzt ist die Strasse da,
wo  i c h  fahre.
Ab und zu finden wir einen Wimpel,
der die eigentliche Route anzeigt.
Dann geht es für einen kurzen Moment
flott voran.
Dann wieder quälend langsam.
* Tragende Musik *
Wir befinden uns
irgendwo im Niemandsland
zwischen gleich da
und unendlich weit weg.
Informationen
will oder kann uns keiner geben.
Solch ein Gefühl
von Abgeschiedenheit und Verlorenheit
kannte ich bisher nicht.
Radikale Entschleunigung.
Beunruhigend, aber auch faszinierend.
* Schuss *
Der Elch hinkt.
Die nervöse Unruhe auf der Ladefläche
erschwert das Zielen.
Waidmanns Glück.
Der angeschossene Elch
flieht ausgerechnet
über die einzige Schneefläche
weit und breit.
Nehmt ihr das ganze Fleisch mit?
Ja, klar.
Fährt das Fleisch bei uns mit?
Ja, ein neuer Passagier.
Was fühlen Sie, wenn Sie das sehen?
Es tut mir schon leid. Aber es wäre
eine Sünde, sich zu beschweren.
Man sollte dankbar sein.
Das ist ein Geschenk der Natur.
Was bedeutet das Tier für Sie?
Das ist zusätzliches Fleisch.
Im Sommer
essen wir oft nur Dosenfleisch.
Das ist Frischfleisch, eine Freude.
Was ist denn Ihr Lieblingsstück?
Suppe aus den Rippen
und die Nieren, gebraten.
Und? Dein Eindruck?
Das wilde Sibirien.
Mit dem Fahrtwind wird's ja
hoffentlich nicht mehr so riechen.
Trotz allem: beeindruckend,
wie Frauen, Männer und Kinder
genau wissen, was zu tun ist.
* Donnergrollen *
Eigentlich wäre das ja ganz lustig,
würden wir nicht geschlagene 6 Std.
mit einem Elch
unter diesem Dach stecken.
* Sanfte Klavier- und Gitarrenmusik,
Regenprasseln *
Die erhabene Grösse und
die Unberührtheit dieser Landschaft
entschädigen
für die Strapazen dieser Reise.
Man spürt,
dass dieser Ort etwas Besonderes ist.
Hier ist das Tor
zum Nationalpark Moma.
Wo ist Sasyr?
Hier.
Und hier ist dann die Rentierherde.
Sasyr ist schön,
aber sehr abgelegen.
Ja, etwas weit.
Die Jungen ziehen weg.
Sie machen Ausbildungen
in der Stadt.
Sie haben fünf Kinder?
Der Mittlere sagt, nach der
8. Klasse komme er zu meiner Herde.
Wir lassen sie ja in die Stadt,
zum Studieren.
Vielleicht
sollte ich sie nicht gehen lassen.
Hier ist es doch viel besser.
Wir sind kurz vor einem Nomadenlager,
wo wir übernachten können.
Von dort, sagt man uns, sei es
vielleicht noch ein Tag bis Sasyr.
Viele der Mitreisenden
haben Verwandte in diesem Lager.
* Sanfte Saitenmusik, Hundebellen *
Auch einige Geschwister von Oigulana
leben hier.
Wie komplett anders das Leben
in dieser Welt doch funktioniert.
Ich bin froh, endlich
mit einem Tee im Warmen zu sitzen.
Doch Oigulana nutzt die kurze Zeit
bis zur Weiterreise
für einen Ausritt.
In einem anderen Lager, 15 km weiter,
sind noch mehr Verwandte von ihr.
Wie sieht es aus?
Wir müssen aussenrum fahren.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
(Originalkommentar) Im Frühjahr,
nach neun Monaten Schule in Sasyr,
darf Christofor endlich heim
zu seiner Herde.
Eine Fahrt,
die selbst für Fahrer Victor
mit seinem Vezdekhod
eine Herausforderung ist.
Nach über 12 Std. muss noch
der letzte Pass bezwungen werden.
Für die Passagiere ist dieser kleine
Sieg über die Natur ein guter Grund,
den Geistern des Waldes
ein Opfer zu bringen.
Für die Ewenen
ist die Passhöhe ein heiliger Ort.
Selbst der russischstämmige Fahrer
Victor
glaubt an die Macht der Geister.
Oh, Geld. 2 Rubel.
Gott hat hier eine andere Form.
Er ist in der Natur.
Ich glaube, der da oben
ist zu weit weg von hier,
um uns hören zu können.
Iegor, schau mal, dort hinten.
Dann endlich der Moment, auf den
Christofor so lange gewartet hat:
das Wiedersehen mit seiner Familie.
Zuerst begrüsst ihn
sein Vater Dimitry,
dann seine Mutter Jekatarina.
Selbst bei den
sonst so zurückhaltenden Ewenen
kann man die Freude
hier und da spüren.
Sasyr ist zum Greifen nah.
Doch noch brauchen wir Geduld.
Der letzte Fluss Moma ist so tief,
dass Vasily nicht
mit Passagieren durchfahren will.
Zum Glück
gibt es hier wieder Handyempfang.
Ein Boot wurde gerufen.
Gut organisiert sind sie hier
am Ende der Welt.
Ein weiterer Lastwagen
ist aus Sasyr gekommen.
Falls etwas schiefgeht.
Das Drehmaterial, meinen Pass
und mein Visum habe ich bei mir.
Alles andere
ist noch auf der Ladefläche.
Jetzt scheinen es sogar die Ewenen
eilig zu haben,
endlich nach Hause zu kommen.
Bei Sonnenaufgang morgens um 2 Uhr
erreichen wir Sasyr.
Noch alles da.
* Hundebellen *
Die Hunde sind auch noch da.
Zuerst verlässt uns
die mittlerweile nüchterne Familie.
Do svidaniya. Spasibo.
Spasibo.
Und, wie war die Reise?
Wir sind daran gewöhnt,
wir reisen oft.
Wann ist die nächste Reise?
Von mir aus schon morgen.
Kanalisation gibt es in Sasyr nicht.
Doch es gibt die Banja,
eine Art Sauna zum Waschen.
Eine Wohltat
nach vier Tagen auf der Ladefläche.
* Ächzen *
Sasyr
ist einer der entlegensten Orte,
an dem Menschen in Russland leben.
Einst wurde das Dorf gegründet,
um die Nomaden sesshaft zu machen.
Mit dem Ende der Sowjetunion
wurde die finanzielle Unterstützung
weniger.
Der Ort
verlor immer mehr an Bedeutung.
Korrespondent Christof scheint hier
am Rande der Zivilisation
ganz in seinem Element zu sein.
Auch ich würde gerne
ein paar Tage hier ausspannen,
doch wir müssen weiter:
zu den Rentiernomaden in den Bergen.
Unsere einzige Möglichkeit,
dorthin zu kommen,
ist Christofs alter Bekannter Victor
mit seinem Vezdekhod.
Doch man sagt uns,
er fahre nicht mehr.
Zdravstvuyte.
Hallo, Europa.
Erinnern Sie sich an mich?
Natürlich, Christof.
Du bist
nur ein bisschen älter geworden.
Spasibo.
Hat dich Sasyr wieder?
Ja, es ist wie ein Sumpf
und lässt dich nicht mehr los.
Möchtet ihr wieder zu den Rentieren?
Das hängt jetzt von Ihnen ab.
Fahren Sie nicht mehr Vezdekhod?
Doch.
Es gibt das Gerücht, man könne Sie
nicht mehr dazu überreden.
Das ging um diese Geologen.
Jetzt habe ich gar nicht gefragt,
wie es Ihnen geht.
Ich will nicht sagen, gut.
Im Winter
hatte ich drei Operationen.
Aber im Sommer
arbeite ich jetzt als Goldwäscher.
Ehrlich? Mit Erfolg?
Ja,
in den Bergen gibt es überall Gold.
Victor verbringt den ganzen Sommer
in den Bergen
und er sei gesund genug,
um Vezdekhod zu fahren.
Die Geologen habe er aus einem
anderen Grund nicht transportiert.
Im Dorf geht die Angst um,
die grossen Goldunternehmen
könnten kommen und Sasyr ausradieren.
Es wird sogar
von einer Initiative gesprochen,
die das Dorf als UNESCO-Kulturerbe
schützen lassen will.
* Entspannte Mundharmonikamusik *
Und schon das nächste Problemchen:
Wir sind hinten zu leicht,
um in diesem Sumpf voranzukommen.
Noch mal kurz die Kette flicken, dann
besorgen wir den nötigen Ballast.
* Motorsäge *
Victor ist der Typ
wortkarger Taiga-Clint-Eastwood.
Gibt es ein Problem,
denkt er im Stillen nach
und dann macht er garantiert
etwas Krasses.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Es ist schön zu wissen,
dass es das noch gibt:
einfach Orte, wo die Zeit
irgendwie relativ richtig ist.
Wo du auch nicht
pünktlich sein kannst.
Weil du einfach nicht weisst,
was geschieht.
Irgendwie hat das was für sich.
Diese Lebensweise zu sehen,
berührt auch mich,
irgendwo ganz tief drin.
Beinahe finde ich es schade,
dass mittlerweile auch hier
jeder ein Handy besitzt.
Ich weiss,
es ist ein romantischer Wunsch,
der mir eigentlich gar nicht zusteht.
Doch ich fände es schön,
wenn der Nomadenjunge Christofor
immer noch so naturverbunden wäre
wie in Christofs Erzählungen.
Ah, da!
* Treibende Klaviermusik *
Da hinten.
Bisschen aufgeregt.
Und du?
- Ich will Rentiere sehen.
Geh einfach.
* Hundebellen *
Zdravstvuyte.
- Zdravstvuyte!
Wie geht es euch?
Gut,
unser Sohn ist erwachsen geworden.
Ist da Luft drin,
oder sind die echt?
Die sind echt.
Kommen Sie rein,
Ihnen ist sicher kalt.
Ja, wir sind 13 Std. gefahren.
Schau mal.
In welcher Klasse warst du damals?
In der fünften.
Wie alt bist du jetzt?
- 17.
Wir erfahren,
dass Christofor auch heute
nur im Sommer bei den Rentieren
und seiner Familie lebt.
Er wohnt jetzt in der Stadt Jakutsk
und macht dort eine Ausbildung
als Baggerfahrer.
Haben Sie geweint,
als er in die Hauptstadt ging?
Wir weinen nicht.
Aber wir haben darauf gehofft,
dass er alles richtig macht.
Er wohnt ja die meiste Zeit alleine.
Wieso ist er schon
nach der 9. Klasse weg?
Er wollte es so.
Jetzt hat er die 11. Klasse
erfolgreich abgeschlossen.
Er hat gute Noten.
Es war sein Wunsch.
Jetzt noch ein Jahr,
dann kann ich in die Armee.
Wieso?
Ich will selbst.
Dort, wo sie mich nehmen.
Nach der Armee
bekommt man leichter eine Arbeit.
Wie gefällt es dir in der Stadt?
Ganz okay.
Ich habe mich daran gewöhnt.
Grosse Reden
schwingt Christofor immer noch nicht.
Noch eine gemütliche Nacht
im Nomadenzelt,
dann sehe auch ich endlich Rentiere.
Jeden Morgen werden sie
von ihren Weiden in den Bergen
ins Lager geholt.
* Erhabene Streichmusik *
Die Rentiere ernähren sich
von diesem Kraut, das Jagel heisst.
Eine Woche dauert es,
bis die Weiden abgefressen sind,
dann zieht das gesamte Lager weiter.
900 Rentiere hat Christofors Familie.
Die Nomaden
produzieren Fleisch und Felle.
Der Export von hier
ist allerdings beinahe unmöglich.
Sie leben hauptsächlich
von staatlichen Subventionen.
Heute ist Medizintag.
* Grunzende Laute *
Christofor scheint
ganz in seinem Element zu sein.
Dennoch konnte er sich
noch nicht entscheiden,
ob seine Zukunft in der Stadt
oder bei den Rentieren liegt.
Was fehlt dir,
wenn du in Jakutsk bist?
Das habe ich doch
gestern schon gesagt.
Dann noch mal.
Die Berge, die Natur, die Rentiere.
Wir werden die Rentiere
auch vermissen.
Sie sind extrem zutraulich,
und sie lieben Salz.
Christofors Eltern haben erkannt,
welch positiven Effekt
der Kontakt mit diesen Tieren
haben kann.
Seit 20 Jahren laden sie Waisenkinder
oder Kinder aus Problemfamilien
dazu ein,
den Sommer hier zu verbringen.
* Ruhige Gitarrenmusik,
vergnügte Rufe *
Den Kindern
tut der Aufenthalt sichtlich gut.
Bist du der Gewinner?
- Da.
Unser Ziel war, dass die Kinder
Rentierzüchter bleiben wollen.
Wir mussten feststellen,
dass die Jungen das nicht wollen.
Die Kinder, die im Sommer
hier waren, werden erwachsen,
sie gehen in die Armee
oder heiraten.
Manche machen eine Ausbildung
und wollen nicht hierher.
In den Ferien kommen sie gerne, sie
erinnern sich manchmal und rufen an.
Das freut uns.
Leider ist unser Aufenthalt wegen
der langen Anreise viel zu kurz.
Vielleicht ist der Teenager
Christofor ganz froh,
wenn diese Fragensteller
endlich wieder weg sind.
Ich jedenfalls bin beeindruckt,
wie offen wir hier empfangen wurden.
* Russischer Sprechgesang *
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es die Menschen sind,
die Rentiere, die Landschaft
oder doch nur die Erschöpfung.
Irgendetwas scheint dieser Ort
mit seinen Besuchern zu machen.
Das ist nur der Wind.
* Melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Und dann erlebe auch ich
meinen sibirischen Moment.
Die Strapazen
werden schnell vergessen sein.
Vorsichtshalber
investiere ich 2 Rubel.
Nicht ganz ausgeschlossen, dass auch
ich noch mal nach Sibirien komme.
Den Nomaden wünsche ich,
dass sie dann immer noch
so leben können wie jetzt.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2020